- So, Sara, what, what was your worst gig?
Did you have like any hecklers or?
- Oh my God, I've had just an,
I play like mellow ballads
as a career choice, like just
imagine the crowds that like,
I, you know anyway,
I have, I have several
moments that come to mind.
One is that I was,
we were doing like a
springtime show where,
on a college campus, they usually pair
pretty disparate artists so
that everybody on the campus
has something to look forward to.
And I was opening for Three Six Mafia
and I was playing a ukulele
- Wait, wait,
wait!
- at the time.
(laughing)
You're welcome world.
- Oh my God, you welcomed
for Three Six Mafia?
- Yes.
- That's my favorite thing.
- I did.
- Oh my God.
Yeah, but Three Six Mafia,
what a juxtaposition of genres.
Okay, yeah.
- Yeah and I got a,
I got a flask thrown at my face
and I did one of these, like
♪ I'm a gentle girl ♪
and then you know
(laughing)
avoiding injury.
And that's, that was one of the times,
I think I cut a song
out on my set at the end
'cause I was like, I,
I, this is not going well anyway,
so that was one of my, I, I've,
I've done all kinds of terrible gigs,
but that was one that pops
to the top of my mind.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
No, we, we definitely all have them.